you see
when we come into this world you have
you like a domestic animal
or an animal growing in a while
so anything that's born from an egg is
an animal
now according to history in our books
humans are the highest form of an animal
it's so we say but as we
come up in life you have babies that was
born
in a home you know raised with character
raised with their families and uh we we
went on this topic what is
the topic before in one of my other
interviews but it's at the same time but
a little different
when we come up into these homes with
our family and our characters and that
you wind up not having a character of
your own because you have put in with a
position where you have to care
and absolutely had to care for others
your brothers your sisters and it wasn't
a choice
for you to care for others this is just
the human way
you share the bathroom we share the
breakfast table
whether we consider it for our mother
and our father so
as you evolve and i've been composed to
animal born in the wild
you get your puppies out there they finn
as they grow their family
like pigeons they they fight for their
food you know
mom teach you how to hunt and then it's
on you
and you know if your brother got a
bigger piece of meat you born in the
wild you got to like a wharf you got to
fight for that meat
you know to get out you know and so you
take a guy
education is something that comes in
every form of life
there's a guy like me you have people
who went to college
and have had high school degrees
opposed to a guy who had never been to
school a day in his life
never had a phone and never he was he's
computer illiterate
he don't read books don't never hardly
ever been to a library or nothing no
brothers no students no wife and kids
but to hear this man speak and the
topics he speak on
you would think that he's been educated
in some of the highest forms of every uh
institutions
that america had to offer but he wasn't
he grew up in the wild born in the y
grew up in the street
but the different cultures he lived in
showed him things and learned him things
like walking down the street looking at
a store window
and standing until you knew how to read
it until you taught yourself how to read
it
so life will evolve for you if you give
it a chance
but the problem with most people is they
see so many things that they want to do
and they want and they want in life that
they really don't give themselves chance
to evolve because they're so hard
pushing themselves so hard
to get the car to go on the cruise to
see rome
paris to have the big house with the
family and the kids
and if these things don't materialize
for them then they
they wear depression set in because you
feel you didn't involve fights
uh far enough in life then you start
looking for other things to blame like
if i had to marry my husband too
soon if i hadn't had the babies too soon
or
if i hadn't listened to my brother my
mother i did what i wanted to do
and these things stress you out and so
by the time you feel you can get it back
on track it has took too many years now
your pensions and your
your retirement funds have come in
jeopardy because you feel like you made
a lot of wrong decisions
when you when when life it's not
racism and it's not the people that's
the enemy
you are your own enemy because you want
so much
and you want more than you can pay for
and when these things don't happen you
wanted to blame the world
people commit suicide kill their babies
storming fires find babies
burning i mean sit down and have babies
at home they put them in the garbage can
they bought them at home everything
and every species we feel we're the
homeless the highest form of species
but if you pay attention to animals
animals don't
sit up and uh turn on you and lie to you
still feed your dog will die for you
and kill for you without any question
but your brother come in the house come
up in the house with y'all when you get
grown
someday y'all will get angry at each
other it won't even speak to you no more
in life
and your own mother will tell your child
to get out the house and never come back
and the child will steal from his own
mother going up first
take his brother's wallet and all this
for a drug
or for a car payment for a pair of
jordan's shoes
and when you say a crackhead or a
heroin head you have to ask yourself
what kind of head am i
because the guy that owns the lexus of
the rolls-royce
he's going to go to work every day and
work hard as he can to pay for that
rolls royce and that mansion out in
beverly hills and the land he lives on
and send his children
to harvard or yale somewhere like that
so they can try to have a good education
within their on his own kids mind
they don't want to do that daddy left me
10 million dollars when will he die
they look at their own fathers and
mothers they say they're too healthy
they're not dying soon we can't get the
wheel
the 10 million the estate the big house
like
in in history and one time again i would
bring this up as the oj trial
in nicole simpson trial bad
feud between the two but he can't let
that girl go
because she feels he'll lose everything
he got so some mutiny has to come into
play
you look at his puppet it's on his
public news so there's nothing here can
be said about that
because it's all over the news this is
just my personal opinion about that
menendez brothers my parents abused us
but they not here to tell you that now
and you killed them
and then you thought you were gonna get
money but they took them through two
trials until they broke them and now far
as i know they may be in prison for the
rest of their lives
i haven't followed up on that but over
the history of time
when you say education education never
stops
because every decade every 10 years
we change technology change things so
whenever you have spent your money to go
to harvard and yale in the 60s
in the 70s you will see that this
knowledge immediately don't count no
more
because the stuff you learned in the 80s
you had to re-educate yourself with the
90s
and for the stuff you learned in the 90s
you wanted to re-educate yourself for
the
and who knows what we're having and what
happened by 2030 we might have spaceship
cars
flying i'm 63 so i don't know that i'll
be here to see that
but you might have red lights up in the
sky and how many tickets would you give
in the sky when you got 50 000 cars
flying and
if you fly past each other doing 70
miles an hour in the big wide open sky
it feels that we don't have to obey a
speed limit up here
and can you put a speed sign up in mid
air and holy stuff
or will they have to build some kind of
entrapment up there
to stick poles in the sky and say you
can't only do
35 miles an hour oh by by this cloud
you know so i'm saying my point is
when you talk about god see a lot of
people when we go to god a lot of people
thought about religion
and we put an evil in a pot and an evil
and a uh a good entity facing each other
that's not what it's about
you see the war in heaven was about
lucifer which was god's might his angels
and god saying i'm going to give the
people what they want to
the cars in the house and all that but
we don't want to learn
too fast so they don't know how to adapt
to these type of things
without hurting each other and we're
killing each other and then what lucifer
argument would be would you want to
control them
why not just put it out there and uh
and let them decide because then they'll
be hurting each other
are you sure about that or do you just
want them under your control
and so then we took it on when the bible
was made we took it as an evil
fighting version but fighting a uh
uh uh a religious thing evil versus uh
positive or whatever you want to say it
good good and evil
but it wasn't about there's like two
brothers come up in the house
and one say well mom said i want to buy
a car but let's get the station wagon no
let's get the camaro over there
but what about the kids same thing in
heaven
let's give it to him let him handle it
but when he didn't go as when god god
controls heaven i'm the father
you're just my son just like you would
go against your own father
in the house i'm your dad we're not
gonna do it like this or you're gonna
get out of my house
but we turned into a war in heaven so he
kicked him out his house
you do what your weight in and so so
he was rich he had power
he wasn't god but he had power had his
own money or whatever
started this thing we call what we call
evil
cars drugs money and the people loved it
and when he went to god his father said
they love it but yes but they're hurting
each other
and they're killing each other behind it
and so we made it that
but we was going to have all the same
things just
one felt like we should have took our
time
and got to adapt to this and learn to
this
because he wanted you to appreciate life
for life
not appreciate life but what it could
give you
or what you could get out of it because
he knew
that someday you will die and you could
not take any of this with you
and if you live like that not
appreciating
life for life and appreciate life for
things
then your children would follow that
like you're like a man come up drinking
in the house beating up his wife
his sons will get drunk and see his dad
doing it
and for you know it 12 years old
slapping the girl bow
the first time it's hard then it gets
easier as you drink the second time it's
easier
the third time you knew the problem with
me is that i never ever hit a girl
called them or caught a lot of girls
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and oars
they ripped me off but could never bring
myself to hit
one because i knew once you cross that
line
there's no point to return like to drink
i never had to drink in my life not
because i was better
because i'm homeless and out here with
everybody else and don't have a dime in
the world no blood no systems again like
i said no wiping kids
but i never took one sip of that alcohol
because when i saw what it was doing to
my friends
i did not want myself to turn into that
i did not hit the crack pipe i did not
do crystal i did not do heroin i did not
do powder coke
but i do do a drug involved marijuana
i don't do this to make myself better
but you will never
ever enjoy life until you can learn to
relax
and appreciate life for life because it
has so much to offer
and we so busy running for things like
you take that game boy or that xbox
you buy a game for your direct box in a
game
and every time you buy a game you got to
buy a new machine
so you have to ask yourself how many
kids i got in my family
and how many machines am i going to buy
and spoil this person
before i decide that i'm not going to
spend another 300
and you take those doors michael jordan
is a damn good basketball player i have
nothing against him
magic johnson all of them are damn good
basketball and i love those people and
on the court
but we don't even know these people and
when they die we cry for them we give
them all our money
three and four hundred dollars for a
pair of jordans and that's nice if you
can afford that because they are pretty
shoes
but if you can't afford that and you
know your child needs to eat
then why would you buy a fair joy not me
i got a pair old
ass air force one nike zone that was
gaining me from a fool line they good
shoes
nice blue and white and thick and they
ain't nowhere near being tore up
but i didn't pay a dime for them and
they might not be as new
as the ones you bought to the store at
300 but they're in good shape
and they're a good-looking shoe and and
they're comfortable
cause they had a little wear on them so
i didn't have to break them in
and i say that as a joking manner to be
more practical people
because life is not going to uh
lay down and just make it easy for you
and remember one thing when you decide
to commit suicide or
besides you're so depressed you want a
mental health but dying is easy
all you gotta do is lay down close your
eyes just lay in the casket
it's living this hard because you feel
you got to get up and face with life's
everyday problems i got to talk to this
person
i got to talk to that person i got to
get home to the babysitter's taking my
kid
i got to refuel the car the husband
ain't doing them just sitting out there
drinking and beating my ass
life is hard and it won't get any easier
until you make it easier and it wasn't a
war in heaven
it was a father arguing with his son
his son wanted to do it one way his
father wanted to do it another
we a lot of us chose the sun weight and
some of us successful
choosing to go with the sunway some of
them got beverly hills
big mansions big beautiful cars
and they thought it was and and it
looked like they made it
so they thought but they didn't because
the people that worked for all that
wearing the pacemakers
catching corona got nerve problems high
blood pressure
running to the stock market in new york
taking dropping aqua saucers and all
kind of
ultra pills and heart pills because the
stock market dropping
wife's talking about lou leaving you
magic johnson got a's
kobe bryant excuse me for the run the
death of his and i'm sorry he's gone
sex problems in denver now he's dead
razer the other guy played with the
football team killed his wife
pregnant wife and baby years ago because
he felt she was getting in the way
everything all this behind material
things
and money and in the end
when you get 60 or 70 80 years old you
say what was it all for
and how many people did i walk on over
those years and hurt
and abuse [ __ ] over
for a price we fought wars years ago
vietnam hitler war vietnam
war alamo to control
population control to save money
to win to have power and control of the
world
and god said no one will have power in
control of the world
the only thing people will do is many
many people will die
because the christians for columbus
discovered
america they say but the energy was here
general custer was a hero
but the indians were here the diamond
mines in africa
so there was no racism no wrong on any
race
my point was that over history man from
all races
have tried to dominate and control
from the martin luther king to the
abraham lincoln heritage of
south native remember these five nations
five assassinations had to happen in
history
to make the world what it is today the
first assassination was jesus christ
then it was abraham lincoln free in the
blacks then it was john f kennedy and
robert f kennedy
that's four six of them then it was
malcolm x and martin luther king
and the only unsuccessful assassination
was ronald reagan who they said had 666
in his name
that was shot in winston and it was a
rumor that they thought he might be the
son of lucifer
because he had the 666 in his name i
guess all the letters in his name added
up to 666. i didn't check on that
but don't quote me on that but it was
something saying about that years ago
spelled his run get his middle name
ronald whatever reagan
and then you can compare that to
yourself this was just a rumor
nothing that i saw in any book or
anything like that
you know so i'm quoting from a room i
heard but he was what he was
they tried to shoot him one time in
washington and he was and he
successfully got through that
then there was watergate with ron with
with our president
nixon so everybody's in control then it
was the thing with uh
fidel castro in his country we wouldn't
let nobody ever control the country kill
people
did whatever he wanted to do you know
there was the old thing with iraq i told
elvaine he wanted to control his company
this is donald train
who they say was killing all this and
doing such and such and such
so then hitler it was men uh and we go
on back down to whatever that
[ __ ] korea name
hondura the conqueror with a great or
something like that
back in asia days so over the history of
time
it's always been proven that people the
domination
all men have tried to dominate the world
without any success
got to a certain point of success but it
always failed till they got to achieve
what they wanted to achieve
because god won the world and forced
your social thing
hey women love sex sex feel good
uh every female is a prostitute and
every man is a trick if you notice to
one most people
when you ask a girl what kind of man she
will i want a man
with a they can provide for me and give
me good security and uh
and then uh and love me and treat me
good and take care of the children and
stay by my side
and then you ask a man would he want
well i would like a girl that would just
love me and obey me and let me go to
work and take care of my kids and take
care of my house and
you know and and always not be so
suspicious of me because you want her to
stay at home and take care of the babies
and not have no questions for you so you
can walk a ride all around in your
private jet
and go out to your nightclubs at night
and have [ __ ] and [ __ ]
all over the city because you're a big
businessman to grow stage from motel to
motel
all over the city and the wife just
won't be a little dumb ass [ __ ]
unless you take all the money and jet
straight around los angeles to all the
nightclubs or
even yet go all the foreign countries
wrong for you people got
you big business man got passports you
think they don't think you got a little
female over there all them female
all them all them beautiful girls in
rome switzerland
australia all them girls looking for
y'all denver colorado
aspen paris new york and you think
you're a woman
like foot locking shoes you see a pair
of jordans today
a new fear come out next week you want
that fair you marry a girl because she
was young and fine and look good
when she get old fat and then have your
baby get stretched more you're looking
for a new pair like them shoes
another young fine small waisted girl
with smooth breasts
and that's the one you're going to be
cheating with and the lady know it
and the kids know it and so now your
sons are cheating too cause they see you
doing and getting drunk and beating up
women and all that too
and your daughter see don't want one man
now
see they they even want boy toys and you
why you wonder why your daughter having
all this
unfamiscuous sex because she started at
home
with you because when you started
cheating your wife your wife said well i
don't give a damn neither
he offered wrong cheating on me i'm
gonna get drunk and bring me a man now
she is she don't bring a man i see her
bring a man out i'll go out honey i'll
be back later
then they get in the car and follow her
to a little to a motel
you know and and see her getting out the
car most she mad at you
now y'all cheating on the daughter
feeling like the [ __ ] i can go on and
slang my little butt too [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's fun
sex is fun excuse me for saying it like
that but you have to give it to him real
and if you teach your daughter and your
son instead of saying
teaching about the the birds and the
bees
and do like my mother told me that's why
i never had no children
she sat me down
she said i'm not gonna chase you all day
like that and tell you to keep that
little dick of yours in your pants
let's get one thing straight she told me
you have a baby you're going to take
care of them or kill you
i won't help you take care of no
children
if you get that responsibility you will
do
this yourself
you run and leave your child support not
mine
and told me that you know if you don't
pay that when they catch up with you you
will have to pay that in back pay
i suggest you think about this
sit down and told me she said you can
drink that liquor
i got cancer you ain't in school
watching me you can get that alcohol
you get drunk you start getting your ass
kicked on alcohol going to jail to
become a loser like your cousin benny
and
you know i'm you know i'm sticking with
cancer you can't help
that's on you and you can get them
tattoos and
join them gangs or do all those hard
drugs
i love you you're my only son
gonna only give it to you like like a
real no matter how young you is
it's not gonna be about the birds and
the bees it's gonna be about the
penitentiary
prisons a lot of bullet wounds nice cars
and you'll win some because i've seen
you
out there in the streets fighting in
school and everything
but you say for everyone you win you get
a little closer to that loss
and you can win a thousand fights
and lose one and that one could be so
devastating
that you'll never recover from it which
means you could die
get paralyzed or go to prison for the
rest of your life
your decision and don't get me wrong
i never had my sex in my life been a
long time probably about 12 13 years
you know and i wanted it that way and i
miss it i like i used to watch porno and
all that and i wanted that high-powered
sex
you know where they free get the girls
in there man and she do some wonderful
things to you and
is every black man dream to get one of
spanish girls one wanting white girls in
the butt or something like that when
having that good powerful sex so i'm
gonna
drug excuse me my language this is only
for this part is only for adults but i'm
just being real
and uh to being honest and truthful with
you
and so it's a lot of black guys dream to
get that fine blonde that you that
lovely brunette or
that soft spanish girl just do lovely
things and y'all just do your thing
about five
six hours and make each other feel good
but at what price you have to pay that
you know i couldn't give a girl
a bunch of crystal and have her come
into town with three four guys
dog out or you know if we was playing
you know she'd do a little thing
just me and her somewhere quiet and i
could respect it and still
you know and we had an enjoyable time
then it was
be something different but for me to
just
take a young girl in a motel or
something and
i know she and i know i'm more older
experienced than her
and if you know she'd have to set me
down 21 22 years old
and let me know in her word does she
want this
because i think we go too far with this
saying we don't respect the women like i
see some guys with
some of the most beautiful women in the
world and they'll hear the drug or hit a
crack pipe or some question and say okay
get out of this sucking
i'll get it turn around let me put it in
and ask them i said do you ever smell
this woman hair
did you ever look at her eyes do you
feel the soft touch of her hand even if
you ain't in love with
just having some good sex do you look at
the smoothness and the soft forms of her
entire body do you look in her eyes and
appreciate
and neil and thank you say thank you
jesus for this good time i'm about to
have here with this beautiful angel
this lovely lady but then we'll get a
drug
and wheelchairs have more concerns for
the drug and the alcohol
then we will the beautiful girl is
sitting up there by naked saying
what about me with buzz and you started
thinking about that pipe or that crystal
that alcohol and i'm laying up here
with all these beautiful golden breasts
on my all my parsons out with all these
lovely beautiful
brewing that soft sticky hair and all
the different places where you like it
and you're not even paying attention to
this
and most men will make women feel like
it's a privilege
to go to bed with them then for them to
go to bed with the privilege
well yeah that is school some say in
some cases
if she a slutty-ass [ __ ] that don't
nobody want
but now you take uh a young lady like uh
because some of y'all are like this
these girls i just don't see you on tv
so i'm using the famous stuff because i
don't know where y'all at out there but
a lot of y'all out there just this
beautiful
of the name up in the polycom you take a
girl like jimmy moore
uh jennifer lopez
you think one of these [ __ ] could hit
that madonna a young madonna
a young janet jackson you think they
would be caught with any one of you
and it wouldn't be about the money with
these people type of ladies
it would be about the honor and respect
you can give them
because these ladies have their own
money
and when they go out and get a boy
that's just for a boy toy
but they would like you to appreciate
and respect what they're giving you and
what they're doing
for you because this type of girl
you can't get but sometimes everyone
somebody screws to the crack and these
type of girls will run up
or whine with the wrong person crystal
crack
and these big dope devils will make you
feel like hey
you need me because you're inferior to
that drug
and you don't if you did if you look if
you look and still look to your left and
you look to your right
he wanted to give you a lot of drugs
and have a little bit of money because
it's just dope more money more
more than just both cars just a nice
pretty car
but the guy on the right wanted to give
you millions and you could have had the
money
to buy your own drug but you didn't take
time
to look to the right because you were so
busy
paying attention to your drug and you
wanted to get high
so you look to the left and you missed
all that on the right where you could
have had the money to buy
your own drug the house the car and
everything
because you were that beautiful but once
you tried heroin
or once you tried that crystal or that
crack pipe
you started getting low self-esteem
and you didn't think you were beautiful
no more
and you didn't think you were you were
worthy no more when you slang that long
brunette in that bronze
red hair that red head or that lovely
brunette blonde and even that armin
and that lovely black hair and white
girls with a lovely long black hair
they're pretty white skin and them blue
eyes
lovely women or that be that beautiful
black woman from
asia and africa or that beautiful black
woman from america like harley
barry when you like to be in a bed with
something like that
instead of being down here with the trap
those are the only ones
that can make these guys feel like they
need them
and when i say trap that don't mean you
mean you're ugly
that means you're beautiful on the other
side but use a [ __ ] on the inside
because some of the most prettiest
ladies in the world
i've seen them right here in skid row
are nothing but [ __ ] and [ __ ]
on the other you think if you go home
and take or take a shower
and change your clothes it just washes
that all the way and then you go out
to the club the next weekend and have
another dick in your mouth
or he'll go out and have another piece
of vagina in his mouth
and y'all started cheating on each other
[ __ ] over each other
and there was no real love ever there
because remember you wanted a man that
could give you good security
supports you you didn't want nothing for
love
you wanted a girl that was all gonna
obey you
and do everything you did and stay at
home and take care of your babies
and look at tv and all over the world on
tv and never go to go to any of these
places
while you go to all these places you
think she gonna sit at home and read
about
where rome and national geographic
or just read about paris and a look at
it on tv while you were there
on your plane but don't want to take the
wife and kids i'm like oh it'd be too
busy
and i don't want to care all y'all cause
you don't want to like you got a lot of
extra baggage holding you down
when you see that lovely female looking
at your big shoulders
and you're looking like miserable in the
car look at that fine i got all these
little babies and this big fat woman
right me
got married 20 years ago
oh she looking look at all that little
young men looking at me i got these
babies
and this big fat slob to sit up in front
of tv and drink all the time
that's what love is all about people all
the things that we hate
not all the things that we love because
if we love if love was like that
then we'd all be happy we got our cars
we got our name we all be happy
love is all about the things that you
hate
you love him so you supposed to go
through that for him
if life was gonna be all smiles all the
time
everybody would love life but it's not
wake up and face reality that big fat
woman you don't want to see no more
that's who you chose to love 30 years
ago get used to it
that's what love finally kicked in when
you first married each other
it was just love just sex good looking
money nice cars
we grew up now it's time to show the
love part
love finally kick in i hate this i hate
this
[ __ ] that's what you're supposed to
feel when you really love her
because once you feel that and stay with
her and go through it
that's when she know that you truly love
her
oh i hate this worthless [ __ ]
drunken sitting in front of tv
that's what you're supposed to feel
about him because once you hate
once you hate you see that and stay with
him
and still go through it that shows him
that you love him
see he know you're going to be there
when you're happy
she know you're going to be there when
she happy the problem is
will you be there when she can't stand
to look at your ass
will she be there when you can't stand
to look at her ass
and better yet will the kids be there
when they can't stand to see neither one
of you [ __ ] fight no more
so who will leave the home first and
then who
will break up this family first
because the one that makes that decision
like the movie set it off
will set it off and make it easier for
the rest of the chain to break down
because once they see him or her do it
the adults
well i don't give a [ __ ] neither i don't
care neither no more we can all just go
our separate ways okay
let's just do that wow
when last time you talking to brother i
ain't talking my brother in 30 years man
we all got 30 years ago i'm calling
well that's how you talk to your sister
i ain't talking that [ __ ] in 15 years
man
that woman hate me
one last time you talked to your dad or
my dad died i never did get to talk to
him no more man
what about your mom when she died and oh
you know i feel my mom living well
somebody else i feel my mom living way
out in wyoming now
she just got old and where's your dad he
moved back to montana
started working on the farms again and
way your sister well she went to college
for a while in california and
somebody gave her some christian then
before i know what she got in college
started on crystal and
i ain't heard from in the last six years
now
huh what about you i had an
embellishment charge and
i was trying to i was working out
the fbi for a long time for the
government i had a good opposite
security but
social security when my wife divorced me
took all the money and i got desperate
and started trying to cut corners and
well i knew what the government had
charges for me for one belgium men and
all that i wound up going
for federal prison for about eight years
and
lost everything i had i got a little
piece of job now security
i was secured working at the library but
it never was insane
what's wrong with you my house burned
down i lost everything but you didn't
lose your life
and the government took everything but
it didn't take your life
and if you get that down and that
depressed
that you feel life is over
because certain events set off certain
other events in your life
and you got so in the dump and feel so
sorry for yourself
that you never did nothing to try to
replace it
you just sit there sad like a big old
sorry nothing and gave up
let me tell you this when i was 12 years
old my mother died
my grandmother asked her he said
if you see a little bit of waterfall
it's tears of joy
not tears of sadness because i'm proud
the way my people brought me up
but my mother my grandmother asked me
when my mother was on a deathbed my
mother died before my grandmother and
she just she followed not long after
he said what is david going to do
you say i taught him everything he need
to know
if he use it
he'll be all right
and i did come out all right now i never
went to school
but i learned how to read very well
anything on the planet
and she gave me an understanding a good
understanding of life
and for the longest i raised myself
and i would walk and i would tell i was
in i would uh
look at things and pay attention and
teach myself to learn
and when i said i was an only child you
have to remember what comes with being
an only child having no family no wife
no children no brothers and sisters
that means i never met her family she
had a lot of sisters and brothers i
never got a chance to meet myself once
the only two people i got to meet with
my grandmother my mother
but now you have to remember what comes
with that when you think you haven't had
a bad life you say you're looking at a
man who have never had a christmas
never had a birthday and never had a
thanksgiving
a easter egg hunt a halloween
never ever having any celebration
for any holiday ever
that existed
but that wasn't society fault
it wasn't anybody's fault
that was just the way life turned out
for me
and i had to accept that
just like you have to accept a lot of
things that you don't want to
and it's not personal it's only life
and it will get easier to deal with as
you
evolve if you give yourself a chance to
learn and pay attention to the things
around you
and remember these three songs
ain't got no kids no more husband no
divorce and left you
don't worry be happy and every little
thing
gonna be all right baby don't worry
and that'll need a baker song ain't no
need to wear it
cause it'll be all over in the morning
and so my point to society
if you don't put so much into life
about what you don't have
and appreciate the things that you do
you won't stress out it's hard
and it won't mean as much
to you no matter what you get
or whatever you lose in life you always
still got your life
and that's what makes me and i doubt
i'll ever have a christmas on birthday
cause i'm 63 years old now
but that doesn't bother me because i've
had a lot of birthdays and a lot of
christmases you know why
because it's not about the president
or what somebody give you
it's about being here 63 years later
where all my friends got shot down from
gang banging uh
killed for some reason unless i went to
prison for life
i'm an old man i have no friends at home
boys left
because it was a hand or dad
or in prison for the rest of their life
and they
had birthdays and they got presents for
christmas
but they're dead are they in prison for
life
i didn't get presents i didn't get
birthdays
[Music]
but i'm alive and free
so no one will have it all no one will
ever have it
all and don't look at this water
well my face should think i'm sad
because i'm not
the man is doing this interview
god brought him into my life and he's a
good man
and before by about two or three miles
two months ago i met this man
before i met him i would still
appreciate life
but it was just a little bit harder
before i met him
and he made it just a little easier for
me
and so no matter how many videos i do
i'll do it all for him and i hope he do
well with him
and i hope he i hope these videos will
help a lot of people
because that's what he's here for to
help people
that he's a good man and he keep
bringing me back
so he can get literature like this not
that he doesn't know it himself
but he want to have somebody who had
been through it
tell him and say this tell it
and he didn't need my help i needed his
and i'm glad he did come in in my life
and i'm hoping that all young people
can use this video and see something
here they can use
and remember it's about living and
enjoying life
not enjoying things because things will
always come and go
with your children and that you would
flesh
that woman your brother your sister your
mother
you'll only have them for a short period
of time that means one day because some
babies die
and then he only died up at birth
so that means you could have you can
have your loved ones from one day
to 100 years but they'll only be here
for a short period
of time and if you don't do the right
thing by them
or by each other while you're here
sometimes you will lose that chance to
do that
and when you lose that chance to do that
it will be something you will regret the
rest of your natural life
in life and in death and you might not
feel it now
because we never miss the things we
truly love until it is gone
and we don't have it no more that's when
we turn around
and we miss it like we used to go to
jail
we would always get to jail when that's
the police catchers and say oh i could
have did this i could have did that
but it's too late now you in jail
it's too late now that person's dead and
gone i moved away
because in the end you got to read no
matter what your belief
is you got to remember cigarette man
belief
is being with god that's why i have
never had a tattoo a pierced ear
a driving license or a phone in my life
i've never had any man made appliances
there no tattoos no pierced ears never
had a driving license
a phone none of that i'm a computer
illiterate
but i have met some good people who have
taught me just as much as that computer
have taught you
so let's have a good day people take
care of your children love your loved
ones
this is me saying goodbye cigarette man
that's great
you